and we're getting some more breaking
news this time from Greece firefighters
have found the bodies of 18 suspected
migrants in an area hit by a major
Wildfire authorities say the bodies were
discovered near a Shack in the
northeastern alexandropolis region there
have not been reports of missing people
in the area so local authorities are
investigating if the victims were
migrants who entered the country from
neighboring turkey let's go straight to
Athens and speak to Al jazeera's John
ceropoulos John what more can you tell
us
well at the moment the fire service is
saying that there are no reports of
missing persons from The Villages and
the towns around the forest in the
Everest region the Border region between
Greece and Turkey where this fire is
still raging and the fire brigades
deduction from that is that these may be
undocumented migrants who crossed the
Everest River into Greece and hit out in
this Forest which is a national park and
therefore not very frequented uh hoping
to evade the attention of police who
have the reputation of picking people up
and turning them around uh and sending
them back to Turkey and this is
something obviously that refugees are
trying to avoid
so they're trying in many cases to make
their way through Greece undetected if
that's the case obviously with tragic
results here local media are making
mention of possible a possible Aid to
further bodies bringing the death toll
to 26 but that has yet to be confirmed
this is a fire that broke out on Monday
early afternoon we're told that it has
now joined up with a different fire that
had been raging in the Alexander bonus
area since Friday and which had almost
been brought under control when high
winds whipped it back up on Monday that
combined firefront now we're told by the
World Wildlife Fund is 110 kilometers
long
um already over the weekend there were
dozens of vehicles hundreds of
firefighters occupied in the area it's
not clear what further resources the
Greek fire service has been able to
bring to bear because these are very hot
dry and windy days in Greece since
Sunday and already on Monday there were
63 reports of new fires we're back in
one of those periods where there are
dozens of fire reports every day if
there aren't enough resources to put
fires out immediately then they can
spread very rapidly in these conditions
uh there was an interview earlier today
from the government spokesman who said
that never before has Greece had this
many days during the summer period with
a level five which is a top level fire
alert uh it's been we've had 10 days of
Heatwave but many more days than that of
level five fire alert so Greece is
obviously breaking new records here uh
there's a lot of discussion about
whether this is the effect of climate
change a lot of people are seeing it in
that light uh certainly this is the
hottest July on record here in Greece
there is a lot of alarm about whether
the country has the resources necessary
to deal with all the fires given that
there are other fires also in the
Mediterranean region there may not be
resources to spare to come to Greece's
Aid so um even today
um a new fire broke out on the outskirts
of
there are some early reports of houses
burning on the outskirts of the city so
as you can imagine there is a state of
great alarm across the country now
all right John ceropoulos reporting from
Athens thank you very much